bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public vous
connaissez notre rendez-vous c'est tous
les jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
sur Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner
du sens à l'actualité avec nos experts
90 minutes et deux débats d'actueux ce
soir la COP 27 pour commencer c'est donc
là 25 27e fois depuis 1995 que les chefs
d'État chef de gouvernement l'obéissent
des ONG prennent des engagements pour la
planète mais comme le rappelle le
secrétaire général des Nations unies
l'ambition n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'urgence
nous sommes sur une autoroute vers
l'enfer climatique le pied toujours sur
l'accélérateur
une cop27 pourquoi faire ce sera notre
premier débat dans une minute et puis
demain les Américains votent pour les
élections de mi-mandat et c'est la
capacité de Joe Biden à gouverner qui
est en jeu les républicains sont ultra
favoris pour l'emporter à la Chambre des
Représentants et sans doute au Sénat et
cela revanche de Donald Trump réponse
tout à l'heure
mais d'abord donc direction Charm el
shake en Egypte une station balnéaire
surnommée le Las Vegas de la plongée
symbole du tourisme de masse pour
accueillir la conférence du climat ça
commence mal Samia de chien
à l'ouverture de la cop27 la communauté
internationale est encore loin de tenir
ses engagements signés en 2015 l'accord
de Paris prévoyait de maintenir le
réchauffement climatique sous la barre
des deux degrés par rapport à l'air
pré-industriel hors d'après les Nations
Unies se réchauffement atteindra 2,4 à
2,6 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
premier enjeu de cette nouvelle
conférence mondiale sur le climat
poussez les États à combler le retard
accumulé tant qu'il est encore temps
nous menons le combat de notre vie et
nous sommes en train de perdre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
continue de croître les températures
mondiales continuent d'augmenter et
notre planète se rapproche rapidement
des points de basculement qui rendront
le chaos climatique irréversible nous
sommes sur une autoroute vers l'enfer
climatique le pied toujours sur
l'accélérateur
deuxième enjeu la justice climatique
pour la première parfois le financement
des dommages est inscrit à l'agenda des
discussions lors de la cop21 les États
les plus riches se sont engagés à verser
100 milliards de dollars par an au pays
en développement qui subissent déjà les
effets du réchauffement climatique
l'objectif n'est pas atteint à la
tribune Emmanuel Macron a appelé tous
les pays à tenir leur promesse pointant
indirectement du doigt les États-Unis et
la Chine nous avons pris des engagements
et il y a aujourd'hui une confiance qui
est en train de s'effriter pour ne pas
dire davantage entre le Nord et le Sud
au fond beaucoup de pays nous entendent
parler de 100 milliards depuis
Copenhague et se disent on ne voit pas
l'argent arriver
[Musique]
nous devons aller au bout de la
solidarité financière on est à 82
milliards d'engagés on doit dans les
tous prochains mois aller au 100
milliards aider à convaincre les
derniers péri riches qui n'ont pas pris
tous leurs engagements sinon la
confiance s'effondrera alors qu'ils sont
ceux qui polluent le moins les pays en
développement subissent les plus gros
dégâts du réchauffement climatique sans
avoir les moyens de protéger leur
population le Pakistan par exemple a vu
un tiers de son territoire recouvert par
les eaux dans de récentes inondations
meurtrières alors qu'il est responsable
de moins de 1% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre coup estimé des dégâts 30
milliards d'euros
voilà les enjeux l'intérêt de cette
cop27 on en débat tout de suite avec mes
invités Françoise Vimeux bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes climatologue
directrice de recherche à l'Institut de
Recherche pour le Développement
Guillaume compas bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi chargé de campagne climat à
Oxfam France Frédéric dans les bonsoir
bienvenue à vous journaliste écrivain
spécialiste des questions
environnementales je cite votre livre
rencontre avec des écolos remarquables
publiés aux éditions de la chaux et
Nestlé on est également en duplex en
visioconférence avec Aurore Mathieu qui
est à Charm el-cheik et qui est
responsable des politiques
internationales du Réseau Action Climat
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là et
Mathieu croissanto éditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue
Françoise vimellé les climatologues nous
nous alerte depuis des décennies la
première Coop c'était 95 à Berlin est-ce
que vous en attendez encore quelque
chose d'une conférence c'est la
conférence des partisans of parties
alors weed d'abord je crois que il faut
quand même reconnaître que c'était un
outil qui est assez indispensable pour
parler du climat et le climat c'est
vraiment une question globale on a
besoin de discuter avec tout le monde et
le monde ayant vraiment ici sa
définition propre donc c'est vraiment le
seul endroit où on peut le faire et je
crois aussi que il faut pas en attendre
trop des cops les engagements se font à
l'intérieur des pays les cops peuvent
pas être à l'avant-garde de ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de chaque pays et
puis il y a aussi ce processus de
consensus qui fait que avec 196 il faut
avoir un avis qui est partagé par tout
le monde et donc forcément j'allais dire
on peut être que déçu ce que je voudrais
quand même le plus petit dénominateur
commun c'est exactement ça mais ce que
je voudrais quand même dire c'est que
aujourd'hui on est sur une trajectoire
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre qui
nous emmène à pas tout à fait 3 degrés à
la fin du siècle et dans
l'avant-dernière plus 3 degrés par
rapport au début du 20e siècle et ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que dans l'avant
dernier rapport du GIEC en 2013 il y
avait des scénarios d'évolution de
température qui nous emmenaient à 5 6
degrés et grâce à ces politiques
environnementales au niveau global et
bien ces scénarios s'éloignent ils sont
de moins en moins probables et puis ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que même si
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
continuent à augmenter au niveau global
elles augmentent aujourd'hui à un rythme
qui est beaucoup plus faible qui est de
l'ordre de 1% par an beaucoup plus
faible que ce qu'on avait au début du
21e siècle qui était de l'ordre de 3%
par an on reviendra là dessus évidemment
mais vous nous dites ça ne va pas assez
vite mais il y a quand même des progrès
c'est intéressant d'avoir ce cette
double perspective Guillaume Compain
c'est un grand barnum c'est le principe
c'est de réunir des des chefs d'État des
chefs de gouvernement qui viennent du
plus de pays possibles donc c'est
forcément un bilan carbone dramatique
une une COP mais il faut quand même y
aller mais c'est quand même un
rendez-vous important oui c'est un
rendez-vous important puisque et vous le
disiez très bien c'est l'un des seuls
endroits autour du monde aujourd'hui ou
les chefs d'État et les représentants de
quasiment tous les pays du monde sont
réunis autour de la table pour discuter
de comment on peut résoudre ce défi qui
est immense et qui est le défi du siècle
de limiter le réchauffement climatique
en dessous de 2 degrés et idéalement en
dessous de 1,5
occasion de se parler quand même mais là
le fait d'être tous ensemble et au même
endroit il y a il y a moins de personnes
de staff peut-être pour pour faire le
tamis je sais pas mais ça crée un
momentum quoi ça crée une occasion de se
réunir tous ensemble d'avoir des
avancées et des étapes pour avancer
puisque on se doute bien que les
négociations elles ont lieu tout au long
de l'année il y a des intercessions à
bonnes chaque année entre les cops donc
évidemment que le dialogue avance au
jour le jour mais c'est comme ça aussi
l'occasion d'avoir une attention qu'elle
soit médiatique qu'elle soit publique
sur ses challenge qui concerne
évidemment les États mais aussi les
grandes entreprises et évidemment les
citoyens
Frédéric dans je le disais en titre
organisé la cop27 à Charm el-cheik est
quand même le symbole du tourisme de
masse c'est quoi c'est une erreur c'est
une ou alors c'est l'occasion de
rappeler que ce modèle de tourisme de
masse il faut qu'il ait vécu le plus
vite possible je sais pas si la
réflexion est allée jusque là ici on
peut on peut faire un lien avec non je
sais pas pourquoi c'est Charmel chair
sans doute parce que c'est plus facile à
sécuriser alors pour y être allé il y a
pire et en face et urghada le vrai Las
Vegas de la plongée d'ailleurs à
l'époque quand j'ai travaillé c'est un
excellent exemple de bonne gestion d'un
parc naturel par les autorités
égyptiennes je détaillerai pas mais
c'était basé sur le le prix justement le
prix de la destruction des récifs
coralliens si on balance une encre si on
plonge mal c'est pas le pire exemple de
du tourisme de masse non c'est pas le
premier exemple mais comme Françoise
elle a dit c'est l'endroit où il faut
être c'est on a tous besoin dans nos
sociétés d'avoir une liturgie cette
liturgie est laïque de manier des
symboles importants qui poussent tout le
monde à être au même moment pour dire la
même chose donc s'il y avait pas eu les
cops et c'est à ça qu'on mesure la
tendance à la hausse n'aurait pas
tendance à baisser année après année
donc mine de rien ça sert à quelque
chose voir ce qu'on aurait honte de ne
rien faire c'est juste du symbolique
mais le symbolique est le plus fort moi
ce que je regrette simplement c'est
qu'on ne fasse pas le lien suffisamment
avec l'autre sujet majeur qui est la
biodiversité dont les sols c'est des
sujets qui sont séparés ils ne devraient
plus l'être d'autant moins que
biodiversité et notamment les sols c'est
un des leviers les plus importants pour
absorber le surplus de carbone qu'on
émet dans l'atmosphère Guillaume compat
est-ce que pour une association pour une
organisation comme la vôtre pardon c'est
aussi une location de faire un bilan
d'étape c'est-à-dire de dire voilà ce
que tel état promis il y a X années
xcope et voilà où on en est exactement
et pour Oxfam par exemple qui est une
organisation de solidarité
internationale notre attention porte
notamment sur ce qu'on appelle les
financements climat c'est à dire c'est
financement que auquel se sont engagés
les pays les plus riches qui ont
bénéficié le plus de la croissance liée
aux émissions d'énergie enfin liées aux
énergies fossiles de se montrer à la
fois solidaire mais surtout responsable
puisque c'est la s'inviter de fournir
des financements donc pour des pays en
développement qui en ont besoin à la
fois pour atténuer leurs émissions mais
aussi pour s'adapter aux conséquences du
changement climatique et une grande
demande qui est faite depuis de
nombreuses années par les pays en
développement notamment les pays
insulaires qui sont menacés d'extinction
par la montée des eaux c'est que ce
qu'on appelle les pertes dommages c'est
à dire toutes les conséquences
naturelles donc des catastrophes
naturelles issues du changement
climatique soit entre guillemets
indemnisés en tout cas qui est une forme
d'aide financière alors on y reviendra
parce que le contenu est pas loin de là
les sponsors de cette cop27 pose aussi
question en tout cas à certains c'est ce
que dénonce l'euro député elle est fi
Manon bon
et sponsorisé par Coca-Cola premier
pollueur plastique au monde par Egyptair
par Microsoft qui le premier financeur
des énergies fossiles bref c'est
difficile de savoir quoi en attente de
cette COP tellement les dernières ont
été décevantes moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'on va un peu de Coop en coop et que
ça devient vous l'espèce de marronnier
télévisuel on en parle au moment de
l'ouverture et puis après on l'oublie
toute l'année or Mathieu vous êtes donc
à charmer le chèque d'abord est-ce que
effectivement l'ambiance est un peu
particulière cette histoire de sponsor
voilà le fait d'être dans une un site
touristique avec autant d'hôtels autant
de climatisation bref c'est pas le plus
important mais quand même je vous pose
la question puisque vous y êtes et puis
surtout pourquoi vous y êtes
alors oui c'est sûr que par rapport à
Glasgow l'année dernière où on s'était
tous rendus en train là l'ambiance c'est
un peu plus particulière on a pris
l'avion on est en effet dans cette ville
un peu dystopique très bétonné mais on a
jugé que c'était important en effet
qu'on vienne tout simplement parce que
on doit mettre la pression aujourd'hui
sur les décideurs politiques on sait que
le contenu est pas que ce soit sur la
réduction des émissions que ce soit sur
la finance climat et il est important
que ce soit les voix des communautés
impactées par le changement climatique
qui soit reflété au sein des cops donc
vraiment l'idée c'est d'investir
l'espace pour aussi contrebalancer toute
l'influence du secteur privé et des
sponsors et pour vraiment faire entendre
la voix des citoyens et des citoyens
dans la recherche des solutions afin
qu'elles soient bien entendu le plus
équitable possible donc très important
pour nous d'être là malgré en effet la
distance alors c'est aussi un lieu ou un
moment mais c'est comme c'est comme
contient un grand salon dans un secteur
d'activité on regroupe les annonces pour
pour la COP par exemple le secrétaire
général de l'ONU Antonio guteresque a
dévoilé un plan de 3 milliards de
dollars pour que d'ici à 5 ans
l'ensemble de la population mondiale
soit protégée par un réseau d'alerte
précoce des catastrophes météo François
Vimeux ça rejoint un peu ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure pourquoi c'est
enfin c'est on sort d'un été
caniculaire en France en Europe on a vu
des images du Pakistan dans le sujet de
Samia de chir pour l'instant pourquoi
cette annonce elle est quand même
importante d'après vous alors l'annonce
en elle-même elle est importante parce
que il y a quelques jours l'ONU a sorti
un rapport nous disons que la moitié des
pays en développement ne possèdent pas
de système d'alerte performants et
efficace et on sait que les systèmes
d'alerte ça fait partie par exemple de
l'adaptation en particulier pour les
pays du Sud et dans les systèmes
d'alerte pour avoir des systèmes
d'alerte par exemple il faut avoir une
bonne prévision météorologique et donc
il y a beaucoup de pays en Afrique
ou la prévision météorologique elle est
elle est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'elle
pourrait être tout simplement par manque
d'observation parce que installer une
station météorologique ça coûte cher la
maintenance de la station ça coûte cher
etc donc je trouve que cette annonce
elle est particulièrement importante à
quoi sert cette cop27 c'est la question
qu'on se pose dans ce dans ce débat on a
commencé à y répondre et vous l'avez
évoqué il y a cet enjeu de solidarité
Nord-Sud qui est vraiment très important
au cœur de de cette de cette COP le
ministre égyptien des Affaires
étrangères qui est également président
de la cop27 il déplore que les nations
riches n'est pas tenu leur promesse de
verser ces 100 milliards de dollars par
an pour aider les pays en développement
à rendre leur économie plus verte on
écoute ça m'échouk oui
des efforts de mobilisation et du
financement climatique suscite de
nombreuses inquiétudes en effet
l'engagement de fournir 100 milliards de
dollars par an n'a pas encore été mis en
oeuvre en outre la plupart des
financements disponibles tant à réduire
les émissions au détriment des efforts
d'adaptation
et la plupart des financements
disponibles sont basés sur des prêts
Guillaume compat même si cet argent
était versé conformément la promesse ça
ne suffirait pas oui tout est résumé en
fait dans cette prise de parole c'est à
dire qu'à la fois le contenu est pas en
volume donc les pays les plus développés
c'était engagés dès 2009 à Copenhague à
verser 100 milliards d'euros de dollars
pardon par an au pays qui en ont besoin
à partir de 2020 en 2020 on était à 83
milliards donc quasiment atteint mais
l'objectif n'est pas rempli et surtout
71% de ses financements climat sont
fournissent sous forme de prêt alors
même si parfois c'est prêt sont à des
taux ce qu'on appelle concessionnelle
donc des taux moins importants ou une
part de dons il n'en reste pas moins que
c'est pas la vision qu'on a nous de la
solidarité puisque c'est prêt implique
de rembourser les prêts parfois avec
intérêt et donc de contribuer dans
certaines circonstances à l'endettement
de pays qui eux-mêmes ont déjà du mal à
cause de ces problèmes de dettes
souveraine à faire face grâce à leur
marge de manœuvre budgétaire assez à ses
besoins
mais comment ça marche est-ce qu'il y a
un organisme qui centralise les
financements ou est-ce que c'est chaque
pays qui décide de financer telle ou tel
pays est-ce que c'est des projets qu'on
finance est-ce que c'est des fonds qui
ont de gouvernement le gouvernement
comment ça fonctionne effectivement il y
a plusieurs sources de financement ça
peut être des aides bilatérales donc
d'un pays à un autre souvent via des
banques publiques de développement c'est
le cas par exemple de la France avec
l'AFD l'Agence française de
développement ça peut être aussi la
Banque mondiale il y a différentes
canaux qui peuvent être soit ambilatéral
soit multilatéraux qui permettent
d'avoir des financements climats qui
arrivent dans les dans les pays
bénéficiaires mais on le voit bien il y
a il y a une diversité de d'approche de
des standards de comptabilisation qui
sont très hétérogènes et l'OCDE qui
recense ce montant en manque de 83
milliards à beaucoup de difficultés à
centraliser ces informations et qui
reflète pas toujours la réalité et un
rapport d'Oxfam qui est sorti à quelques
semaines des membres d'ailleurs que si
on s'en tient au fond qui sont
réellement
transférés en fait des pays riches vers
les pays le plus pauvre on est plutôt
sur de l'ordre de 21 à 25 milliards de
dollars au lieu des 83 annoncés il y a
une question Matthieu d’acceptation par
les opinions publiques dans certains
pays moi je pense en vous entendez je
pensais à ce qui à la réaction de
certains camps politiques à l'aide à
l'Ukraine par exemple on pourrait faire
le parallèle quoi il y a une il y a une
difficulté à faire accepter par certains
des électeurs le fait d'aider les pays
du Sud tout simplement oui en même temps
il y a une prise de conscience quand
même dans l'opinion qui est réel de la
nécessité de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique alors après le
problème c'est qu'on sait pas très bien
où ça va comment ça se passe qui fait
des efforts et il y a quand même une
profonde injustice aussi qui est qu'on
demande au pays du Sud de faire des
efforts pour corriger un réchauffement
climatique qu'on a largement en
contribué nous baie du Nord et pays
riches en particulier à alimenter et
donc cette espèce de hiatus dans
l'opinion publique internationale avec
vous voyez dans les pays du Sud des gens
qui disent après tout pourquoi nous on
irait faire les efforts que que vous
nous demandez alors qu'on n'a pas la
croissance on n'a pas eu le temps de se
développer on a pas eu l'argent pour
c'est de de multinationales qui lancent
des programmes pour changer leur
trajectoire des problèmes de transition
écologique il y a parfois des salariés
de pays en développement qui nous est
bien gentil mais c'est pas à nous de
freiner quoi donc c'est effectivement
intéressant je voudrais qu'on parle des
des catastrophes à venir en quelque
sorte on est sur une trajectoire bah oui
mais on est sur une trajectoire de alors
3 degrés si on fait rien peut-être qu'on
réussira si on a pu un peu plus fort sur
le frein comme disait Anthony whithérèse
à flirter avec les deux degrés mais ça
veut dire quoi en terme de catastrophe
climatique en fait c'est assez simple
c'est à dire que à chaque dixième de
degrés comprend on intensifie
les impacts du changement climatique
donc si on parle par exemple des
événements météorologiques extrêmes on
sait que à chaque dixième de degrés en
plus on vient rendre ces événements plus
intenses surtout plus fréquent pour les
vagues de chaleur on sait qu'elles
seront plus longues que la saison
estivale pourra s'étaler et donc elles
pourront à venir plus tôt ou bien plus
tard dans la saison ça peut être aussi
des impacts qui viennent de ce qu'on
appelle les composantes lentes du
système climatique comme par exemple
l'élévation du niveau des mers dans un
monde par exemple si je compare ce que
serait un monde à plus 1,5 degrés et un
monde à plus de degrés c'est 10 cm
d'élévation du niveau des maires de
différence alors ça paraît rien 10 cm
mais quand vous habitez sur la côte déjà
au niveau de la mer et bien 10 cm ça
fait que vous migrez ou vous restez donc
ça c'est c'est vraiment très important
et puis après il y a tout un tas
d'impact alors je pense les impacts sur
notre santé sur notre bien-être sur la
pénurie d'eau on sait encore une fois si
je compare ces deux mondes à 1,5 et 2
degrés on sait que dans un monde à 1,5
degrés il y a deux fois moins de
personnes touchées par la pénurie d'eau
que dans un monde à deux degrés donc
c'est énormément de de conséquences et
d'impacts différents je disais que cette
cop27 elle sert aussi à des annonces
publiques à par exemple et je me tourne
vers vous hors Mathieu une alliance pour
la résil face à la sécheresse qui a été
annoncé tout à l'heure par 25 pays et 20
organisent des pays d'Afrique des pays
d'Europe notamment l'Espagne également
le Sénégal
qu'est-ce que vous vous attendez en
terme d'annonce parce que vous êtes
là-bas vous dites on veut peser sur les
chefs d'État évidemment tout ça a été
anticipé négocier dans les semaines qui
qui ont précédé la cop27 c'est-à-dire
que là vous allez peser pour la
prochaine coop en quelque sorte si
j'essaie de bien comprendre
non alors déjà nous on essaie de peser
en effet sur les annonces qui vont être
faits c'est à dire que aujourd'hui les
pays du Sud ce qui va être concrètement
c'est plus de finances il valent plus de
finances pour l'adaptation ils veulent
plus de finances sous forme de dons et
ils veulent de la finance pour répondre
aux conséquences du changement
climatique ce qu'on appelle les pertes
dommages donc tout ça en fait c'est
vraiment ce qu'on attend concrètement de
ces de ces discours qui vont être faits
et qui pèsent un peu sur les
négociations les négociations elles
viennent juste de démarrer et nous on a
aussi ce rôle de s'assurer que dans les
textes qui vont être adoptés sur les
différents sujets de négociation à
l'agenda qui parlent notamment réduction
des émissions adaptation finance climat
de s'assurer que les décisions qui sont
prises sont les plus ambitieuses
possibles donc là il s'agit vraiment
d'un travail de suivi des négociations
aller dans les salles essayer de savoir
ce qui s'est dit de connaître les
positions des différents pays quelle est
la position de la France sur tel tel
sujet et nous après de pousser les
représentants français ici sur place à
Charles etcher pour avoir justement des
décisions qui soient les plus juste et
les plus ambitieuses possibles donc
c'est vraiment de voler des négociations
entre le côté un peu politique des
annonces et le côté technique qui va
vraiment influer sur ce qui va sortir de
cette coque une information de cette fin
d'après-midi des chiffres donnés par
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
15000 décès en Europe due au canicule
cet été Guillaume compensé horrible à
dire mais des chiffres comme celui-là
ils participent de la prise de
conscience dont on parlait Mathieu à
l'instant c'est une c'est une évidence
de le dire mais on est dans un dans une
logique aussi de lobby dans une coop
comme celle-là il y a différents lobbys
qui se qui s'affrontent il faut il faut
pas être angélique sur ce qui se passe
dans une communauté donc est-ce que pour
vous cette prise de conscience elle
touche aussi ceux qui pourraient tenter
de freiner les gouvernements sur le fait
de de moins utiliser les énergies
fossiles ou de développer l'éolien ou de
etc etc
oui bah je pense que on commence
malheureusement à constaté y compris en
France la violence des impacts du
changement climatique qui jusqu'à
présent nous ont relativement je dis
bien relativement épargné par leur
fréquences et leur intensité
effectivement on sait très bien que plus
les années vont passer plus c'est
événements climatiques extrêmes vont
être forts y compris chez nous et donc
je pense que ça participe aussi à la
sensibilisation des citoyens européens
par exemple et aussi des décideurs qui
le voient de plus près qu'avant ou c'est
catastrophe climatique qui existent
depuis déjà des décennies dans beaucoup
de pays plus vulnérables
par exemple un rapport est sorti
récemment montrant que depuis 30 ans
donc c'est à dire depuis le début des
cops et depuis le moment où les pays qui
sont menacés comme je disais de
disparition par exemple par monter des
lots des eaux demande un mécanisme
financier pour les pertes dommage depuis
30 ans on estime qu'à peu près 190
millions de personnes dans les pays en
développement sont affectés chaque année
par la catastrophe naturelle issue du
changement climatique donc on voit bien
que que cette violence elle se elle se
déferle déferle déjà depuis des années
dans les pays en développement mais
c'est vrai que le fait que ça nous
impacte peut-être plus directement
aujourd'hui dans des pays plus riches
permet aussi sûrement d'augmenter cette
prise de conscience oui avec je reviens
au secteur si on prend le secteur des
énergies fossiles il est confronté à
quoi il est confronté à des difficultés
de recruter des des jeunes talents et
les confronté à des questions
d'investissement enfin ce ce cet effet
catastrophe climatique opinion publique
pollueur il est pas neutre quoi il est
temps il est en cours le levier est en
cours le levier est en cours en tout cas
on souhaite que que ce je pense la prise
de conscience elle est là elle est
claire tous les toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion montre que la grande majorité
des Français non seulement sont
conscients du problème du changement
climatique mais sont inquiets et
souhaite que que des mesures soient
prises et prennent pas aussi à cette à
ce changement de pratique mais ce qui
est ce qui est assez clair dans c'est
qu'on voit que il y a une demande
vraiment de partage de l'effort il y a
les personnes vont consentir évidemment
à faire des efforts mais il faut que
tout le monde les fasse et on n'est pas
tous logés à la même ancienne de ce
point de vue là par exemple aujourd'hui
ou que ça m'international sort un
rapport qui montre que les émissions de
125 milliardaires dans le monde à
travers leurs investissements dans des
grandes entreprises multinationales
contribuent à autant d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre que le territoire
français on voit bien une énorme
différence avec le français moyen entre
guillemets sachant que à travers le 125
milliardaires c'est à dire que les
portefeuilles d'investissement de 125
personnes 125 vis c'est pas la vie
quotidienne
les investissent effectivement c'est à
dire que nous on estime jette c'est pas
des jets c'est pas leur consommation
même si leur consommation est
exorbitante en termes d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre par rapport à la
plupart d'entre nous je pense ici cela
étant là on parle vraiment des
investissements parce que on estime chez
Oxfam que c'est milliardaire sont
souvent parfois trois sièges à des
conseils d'administration de grande
entreprise parfois les ont même créé ces
grandes entreprises et ont donc un
pouvoir d'action énorme bien plus
important que que le commun des mortels
pour changer les trajectoires de ces
grandes organisations puisqu'on parle de
milliardaires la Fondation Bill et
Mélinda Gates donne un ça a été une des
annonces aujourd'hui j'en ai noté
quelques-unes 1,4 milliards de dollars
sur 4 ans aux petits agriculteurs en
Afrique pour s'adapter au changement
climatique
je reprends ma question sur les Frédéric
denrées je me tourne vers vous sur
finalement les les géants de des
énergies fossiles aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes aussi optimiste que moi sur le
changement de modèle et sur la nouvelle
trajectoire ou est-ce que vous dites
nous on séduire une washing il y a
quelques il y a quelques leviers
d'activés sur une petite partie du
chiffre d'affaires mais en fait ils sont
en train de défendre leur modèle ouais
mais le modèle ils savent très bien
qu'il est qu'il est foutu qu'il est il
change pas ils sont morts quoi si change
pas ils sont morts c'est pour ça que
Total est devenu total énergie et
investi au maximum dans les énergies ren
mais même les pays du golf sont en train
tout doucement de changer leurs
investissements de façon à être à
devenir peut-être des pays de touristes
plus que des pays du pétrole ça prendra
du temps c'est beaucoup trop long mais
le changement est pris puis vous l'avez
dit le name and shame fait que dans les
grands groupes effectivement on a du mal
à recruter des ingénieurs pour des
entreprises entre guillemets salle mais
ça s'applique aussi au nucléaire
d'ailleurs ce qui est un peu un peu
paradoxal mais non non c'est pas que du
greenwhin d'ailleurs le greenwashing moi
je l'ai vu il y a 30 ans le greenwashing
eu un effet très pervers c'est-à-dire je
suis grande entreprise je mets une
couche de peinture mais c'est une
peinture très toxique qui diffuse
jusqu'à l'intérieur jusqu'à la tête des
salariés qui a un moment ou un autre
demande des comptes alors je sais je
l'ai vu partout donc ça a été une arme à
double tranchant d'ailleurs une autre
arme à double tranchant c'est
effectivement de de cibler 125
milliardaires on peut se dire très bien
on peut se dire mais puisque c'est eux
c'est intéressant parce que on peut
aussi utiliser le même argument quand on
compare l'impact des pays les plus
pollueurs on a regardé quels étaient les
plus gros pollueurs en 2020 la Chine
c'est près de 10 milliards de tonnes de
CO2 États-Unis 4,5 milliards l'un de ces
2,3 milliards la Russie 1,5 milliards le
président chinois si Jean Ping ne sera
pas présent à cette cop27 Frédéric non
je reste avec vous donc on se dit bah
pourtant si la Chine s'en fout à quoi ça
pardon je suis un peu trivial pardon
mais à quoi ça sert quoi
puis si vous rapportez les émissions de
la Chine et la population chinoise bah
finalement ils émettent moins que nous
c'est toujours pareil les pays qui
mettent le plus oui mais si la Chine et
les Etats-Unis sont pas sont pas à la
manœuvre à la COP 27 à quoi ça sert dit
à quoi la Chine fait plus d'efforts que
les Américains qui en font très peu vous
savez que le modèle de vie américain est
non négociable a dit un ancien président
la Chine qu'on vous regardez son
investissement sur les technologies de
rupture quand vous regardez ces
investissements en termes de de
dépollution de décarbonation elle va
plus vite que nous je reprends l'exemple
du nucléaire nous qui avons quasiment
tout arrêter qu'avant arrêté le
président Macron les recherches sur la
4e génération de réacteur c'est la Chine
qui a pris la main derrière c'est la
Chine qui a pris la main sur les
batteries c'est la Chine qui a pris la
main sur les énergies renouvelables donc
effectivement on peut dire qu'elle
pollue beaucoup mais elle va beaucoup
plus vite que nous dans la prise en
compte des questions environnementales
nous on a mis 30 ans en gros
ils vont ils vont aller plus vite que
nous alors c'est intéressant parce que
c'est pas exactement ce que nous disait
Emmanuel Macron ce matin quand il dit
les Européens paient mais on est les
seuls
et derrière il faut qu'on ait des
États-Unis et la Chine qui soit vraiment
au rendez-vous et si je devais
simplifier les choses sur les émissions
notre bataille c'est que les plus riches
soient là qui payent leur juste part et
là-dessus soyons aussi clair j'ai besoin
qu'on se dise des choses les Européens
paient on est mais simplement le
problème c'est qu'on est les seuls à
payer
et donc là il faut être aussi mettre la
pression sur les pays riches non
européens
pour leur dire vous devez payer votre
part et puis alors autre son de cloche
qui va dans le même sens celui d'Antonio
guteres le secrétaire général de l'ONU
ça sont les les interventions un peu
marquantes de ce début de journée à
sharm-elflick
de tout les deux plus grandes économies
les États-Unis et la Chine ont la
responsabilité particulière de joindre
leurs efforts pour faire de ce pas une
réalité
c'est notre seul espoir d'atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques
l'humanité a le choix coopérer au périr
c'est soit un pacte de solidarité
climatique soit un pacte de suicide
collectif
les mots forts comme toujours d'Antonio
guteres Françoise Vimeu
j'entends bien ce que nous dit Frédéric
non mais
sans les États-Unis et la Chine on
pourrait rajouter l'Inde mais bon
la trajectoire dont on parle et dont on
rêve qui est quand même trajectoire
d'augmentation de de degrés c'est pas
non plus c'est pas non plus un grand
succès si on y arrive mais c'est
possible ou pas ou ça n'est possible que
si toutes les économies les plus fortes
ils vont alors plusieurs choses d'abord
effectivement c'est un problème mondial
donc si un seul pays décide de diminuer
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
ne fonctionne pas après il y a des
représentants quand même de la Chine et
des États-Unis
c'est pas forcément ça qui est un pas en
tout cas à mes yeux c'est pas forcément
ça qui est important ce qui est
important c'est qui est des négociations
après pour compléter ce que ce que dit
Frédéric et je suis tout à fait d'accord
la Chine enfin les observateurs disent
que le pic
une émission de gaz à effet de serre
pourrait arriver plutôt que prévu donc
c'était prévu en 2030 et pourrait
arriver en 2025 parce qu'il y a aussi ce
côté challenging et la culture chinoise
fait qu'on aime bien ce côté challenging
peut-être ils aimeraient bien être les
premiers à réussir à faire ce que tous
les autres n'arrivent pas à faire et
c'est terminé je vous parle un aspect
important que vous dites voilà mais si
les États-Unis sont pas là si la Chine
est pas là à quoi ça sert c'est un petit
peu les arguments
qui sont par certains climatosceptiques
ou rationnel à quoi ça sert qu'on fasse
quelque chose voilà parce que ça leur
permet d'avoir un alibi pour ne rien
faire et donc moi je me méfie énormément
de ce genre de discours on est bien
d'accord
attendez est-ce que j'ai oublié la
question que je voulais vous poser non
laissez retard les fait retard c'est à
dire que si parce que vous lui dites il
disait 2030 mais peut-être 2025 donc il
se passe combien de temps peut-être que
vous avez pas la réponse vous êtes trop
compliqué mais entre le moment où un
état décide vraiment d'appuyer sur le
frein et le moment où ça se ressent dans
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors en fait c'est ça c'est assez clair
à partir du moment où on prend des
mesures drastiques pour diminuer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et que
effectivement la la concentration se
stabilise dans notre atmosphère et
comment ça diminuer l'effet sur la
température de l'atmosphère c'est 20 à
30 ans c'est un effet assez rapide
finalement c'est à l'échelle d'une vie
humaine en revanche si on parle de la
montée du niveau des mers c'est pas du
tout comparable même si on arrête
complètement les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans 1000 ans le niveau
des mers continuera à augmenter parce
que là on est dans les composantes
plantes et dans une inertie énorme du
système climatique mais donc ce que je
veux dire aussi par là c'est que
finalement tout n'est pas perdu il y a
de l'espoir on sait exactement pour
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degrés
qu'il faut diminuer les émissions de 43%
d'ici 2030 par rapport à leur niveau de
2019 alors on peut décider de se dire
bah voilà effectivement là maintenant il
faut vraiment y aller et la fenêtre est
encore ouverte mais elle se referme jour
après jour on va faire un focus
maintenant ouvrir un chapitre concernant
la France et peut-être le bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron Mathieu vous penchez
sur ce qualificatif qui revient souvent
chez ceux qui critiquent le président de
la République président de l'inaction
climatique
Yannick Jadot lors de son admonestation
d'Emmanuel Macron au Parlement européen
elle a été en cœur par les insoumis
qu'on avait fait un des thèmes de leurs
marches le 16 octobre avec avec la vie
chère elle-même était reprise par des
socialistes au premier rang desquels le
premier secrétaire du PS Olivier Faure
pourquoi parce que cette formule à
l'avantage à la fois de Tenser un bilan
et claque comme un verdict et puis elle
résonne même comme la pire des
compromissions au fond puisque c'est
celle du laisser faire ou plutôt d'une
ne rien faire qui serait érigé au rang
de politique alors d'où ça vient cette
expression ça monte à Caen et bien quand
on regarde l'expression elle vient dans
le débat public en fait par le biais de
grand public par le biais de deux
recours déposé devant le conseil des tas
qu'on va buter des décisions de justice
la première à la demande du maire de
Grande-Synthe de la commune de
Grande-Synthe dans le Nord la seconde à
l'initiative d'un collectif qui
réunissait quatre ONG portant l'affaire
du siècle vous vous souvenez aussi sur
pétition qui avait réuni 2,3 millions de
personnes et dans ces cas la France
s'est fait condamner en 2020 et en 2021
pour manquement à ses engagements mais
précision importante c'est l'État en
tant que personne morale qui était
condamné pour ces manquements et non
gouvernement ni même Emmanuel Macron
cerise sur le gâteau c'est qu'on a
nation elle incriminait la période 2015
2018 et donc pour moitié un temps où
c'était François Hollande le président
et le gouvernement comptait dans ses
rang de l'équipe des socialistes des
écologistes c'est la même qui
instruisent aujourd'hui le fameux procès
en inaction climatique contre manuel
Macron et dans leur recours au signaler
d'ailleurs que la requérants ne visait
pas précisément le président de la
République mais bien l'état plus
globalement mais alors qu'est-ce que ça
traduit Emmanuel Macron repose ici un
déficit de politique et un déficit de
communication sur son action en faveur
de l'écologie alors faut bien connaître
que toutes les mesures toutes les
annonces toutes les promesses qu'il fait
aujourd'hui ils auraient pu être
engagées lors du précédent quinquennat
on aurait gagné du temps le diagnostic
et les solutions c'était plutôt les
mêmes ils étaient connus il manquait une
impulsion etc pulsion il faut le
reconnaître on a plutôt été donné par la
guerre en Ukraine et la problématique de
pouvoir d'achat que par tout un coup une
conversion à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et c'est à dire
pour autant qu'on peut qualifier sa
politique d'inaction autrement dit
confirmé qu'il n'a rien fait non ce
serait abusif il y a eu des avancées en
la matière je vais vous dire autant si
ce n'est plus que les quinquennat de
Nicolas Sarkozy et de François Hollande
réunis c'était on dirait c'était
difficile de faire de faire pire il y a
eu des coups d'arrêt pour plusieurs
projets écologiques alors je pense je
parle d'écologie au sens large celui de
l'aéroport de Notre-Dame-des-Landes
celui de la mine d'or de la Montagne
d'Or celui de l'arrêt de Fessenheim qui
avait promis François Hollande qui
n'avait pas fait il y a eu des lois qui
ont été votées sur l'économie circulaire
sur la mobilité sur l'agriculture et
l'alimentation on avait eu sur le climat
rappelons qu'il est la création d'un
Haut Conseil pour le climat il y a une
convention citoyenne alors c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois on dit oui mais ce
n'est pas suffisant ça n'allait pas
assez loin mais en tout cas c'est les
choses qui ont été faites qui n'avaient
pas été faites avant rappelons aussi
qu'il avait même prévu d'augmenter la
taxe carbone en 2019 avant que ça ne
déclenche le mouvement des gilets jaunes
et que je n'ai pas le souvenir qu'à
l'époque les insoumis les socialistes et
les écologistes se dit ouais si il faut
augmenter la taxe carbone ils étaient
plutôt enfin je crois les écologie je
les mets à part mais les insoumis et les
et les insoumis étaient plutôt du côté
des gilets jaunes
mais le problème c'est que pour se
construire une image en politique faut
d'abord des résultats et des résultats
pour le coup ils sont insuffisants ça
c'est clair et puis il faut de la
lisibilité et on en a manqué aussi et
puis il faut en fin de la cohérence et
pour le coup les valves hésitations
d'Emmanuel Macron sur le nucléaire la
démission de Nicolas Hulot les
tergiversations sur les écologistes un
coup traité de partenaire un coup traité
d'amish et ben tout ça ça brouillé la
ligne le message faisant d'Emmanuel
Macron sans doute pas le président de
l'inaction climatique mais sans doute
plus le président de la confusion
climatique la confusion climatique
Guillaume c'est pas facile parce que là
on a eu un bilan
assez exhaustif mais vous qu'est-ce qui
ressort en premier dans la peut-être
dans la colonne plus et puis après dans
la colonne moi si vous voulez bien ou
dans l'autre ordre comme vous voulez non
mais alors je parle notamment en tant
que représentant d'Auxonne qui est des
quatre associations du coup qui a qui le
recours de l'affaire du siècle donc
effectivement on a contribué à peut-être
à diffuser ce vocabulaire dans dans
l'opinion publique et
principalement parce que
effectivement vous le disait et ça ça
m'aide au crédit d'Emmanuel Macron ça
date pas de quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron l'insuffisance de l'État en la
matière et typiquement ce qui avait été
reproché c'est qu'effectivement la
France qui s'est définie désormais une
stratégie nationale bas carbone donc
c'est à dire une sorte de budget carbone
dans différents secteurs à ne pas
dépasser sur un certain nombre d'années
n'avait pas respecté ses engagements
entre 2015 et 2018 d'où le recours et
donc le tribunal administratif de Paris
avait estimé que l'État devait compenser
le préjudice écologique et sur la
nouvelle période qui qui se termine
bientôt
nous ce qui nous emmène c'est que
l'ambition française a été abaissée par
le Président de la République et par son
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on s'est
fixé des objectifs moins élevés qu'on va
peut-être atteindre on ne sait même pas
mais en tout cas ça pour nous c'est
clairement un très mauvais signal en
matière d'ambition et on verra ce que ça
donne et puis les d'autres éléments
c'est effectivement cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui était à son
crédit une très bonne initiative pour
essayer de réconcilier les français
aussi pour voir quelle stratégie on
pouvait prendre collectivement
malheureusement quand on reprend
quasiment aucune des mesures proposées
par la Convention citoyenne le message
est dramatique et à juste titre et
d'ailleurs on voit bien aujourd'hui que
une majorité des Français sont en faveur
par exemple d'une réduction de la
vitesse sur l'autoroute à 110 km/h parce
qu'ils comprennent bien que à la fois
pour des questions écologiques mais
également pour leur portefeuille c'est
une solution qui est très utile et
précieuse à l'époque cette solution
avait été proposée par convention
citoyenne n'avait pas été retenu il y a
une loi c'est le fameux paquet climat
cette année pour vous elle était
évidemment insuffisante elle était
insuffisante et notamment par exemple on
parlait de l'agriculture en réalité dans
le domaine agricole très peu de
politique nous dirige vers une
agriculture qui soit bas carbone et qui
ne contribue pas à augmenter fortement
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
bien au contraire c'est l'inverse qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec encore énormément
de concessions faites à l'élevage
intensif qui doit qui doit se réduire
dans les prochaines années on va parler
une politique énergétique en restant
dans ce chapitre sur la France grâce à
Steve Jourdain puisque un texte a été
adopté en fin de semaine dernière par le
Sénat projet de loi du gouvernement sur
les énergies renouvelables bonsoir Steve
bienvenue l'objectif c'est de rattraper
notre retard le Sénat demandé aussi à ce
que l'installation de ces projets ne se
fasse pas contre la vie des populations
locales et pour cela la droite proposer
de donner un droit de veto au maire les
élus auraient pu en dernier ressort dire
oui ou non un projet d'installation dans
leur commune par exemple en matière
d'éoliennes hors de question pour le
gouvernement qui est parvenu à faire
adopter un dispositif plus souple le
texte tel qu'il a été adopté par le
Sénat prévoit plusieurs choses et tout
d'abord une planification territoriale
des énergies renouvelables les mers
pourront définir eux-mêmes en amont les
zones géographiques qui pourront ou non
accueillir les projets autre mesure
adopter l'installation quasi
systématique de panneaux solaires sur
les grands partis parking il y a parfois
vous le savez des ombrières au dessus
des des voitures de parking des grandes
surfaces et à partir de l'été prochain
les structures devront produire de
l'énergie en plus de protéger les
voitures du soleil et puis troisième
grande mesure adoptée par le Sénat des
les ristourne sur les factures
d'électricité les collectivités qui
accueillent des énergies renouvelables
sur leur territoire obtiendront un
rabais sur leur facture ça permet de
rendre ses énergies plus attractives
demain c'est le résultat d'un compromis
entre le Sénat gouvernement oui c'est en
tout cas ceux qui mis en avant par les
responsables politiques il faut dire que
le texte a été adopté à une très large
majorité du Sénat même les républicains
qui avaient beaucoup de réserves sur ce
texte et bien ont voté pour ce compromis
écouté largement laissé la place aux
apports du Sénat ces apports montrent
l'intérêt
l'urgence partagée sur tous ces bancs la
volonté d'avancer et un objectif commun
qui nous avait amené à commencer par le
Sénat qui était de poser les bases d'une
planification et d'embarquer les élus
locaux comme partenaire le gouvernement
le compromis gouvernement Sénat aura
peut-être des implications politiques
plus larges en Thomas puisque les
républicains au Sénat aux donc voté en
faveur de ce texte reste à voir
maintenant ce que les députés LR vont
faire puisque le texte sera débattu le 5
décembre prochain à l'Assemblée
nationale merci Steve Jourdain un mot
Frédéric Denise sur le le calendrier en
fait est sur l'hypothèse de d'alléger
les procédures pour faire avancer ces
projets alors ça ça vaut pour le
nucléaire mais ça vaut aussi pour les
projets de d'éolien c'est une obligation
pour aller plus vite
mais c'est peut-être un peu moins de
démocratie comment vous l'analysez ça
attention on a tellement pris les choses
en retard ça fait 30 ans que la
politique énergétique n'est pas pensée
ça fait 30 ans qu'il y a pas de
politique énergétique d'un gouvernement
à l'autre souvent pour des besoins
électoraux un coup on arrête le
nucléaire un confirme une centrale à
coup finalement ferme pas on va
développer les énergies renouvel on fait
tout pour qu'elle se développe pas mais
aujourd'hui on est au pied du mur on est
au pied du mur avec en plus la guerre en
Ukraine qui montre qui amplifie le rôle
dévastateur du marché privé auquel on a
confié l'électricité avec les
conséquences que ça sur le peu sur le
sur le prix l'énergie oui on fait tout
dans l'urgence enfin on avait un état
planificateur de vin étagère on avait
des stratèges à la tête de l'État sortie
des plus grandes écoles c'est terminé
depuis 30 ans et là on en paye le prix
qui est celui de devoir accéléré alors
je leur souhaite bien du plaisir parce
que pour avoir participé à des débats à
voir animé des réunions sur les
éoliennes je peux vous dire que c'est
compliqué les gens ne veulent plus qu'on
touche à leur paysage autant ils le
voulait dans les années 60 quand on le
mettait une ligne à trop haute tension
parce que ça apportait un confort inédit
autant là ils n'en mesure pas le
bénéfice on a beau dire que c'est
l'électricité verte ça reste de
l'électricité donc on va vers des gros
gros conflits
qui seront pas réglés par ces procédures
qui effectivement vous l'avez dit Thomas
altère la démocratie et là on voit ce
vers quoi on va au pied du mur la
démocratie frappe place à
l'autoritarisme d'une façon ou d'une
autre malheureusement mais on paye 30
ans d'inaction et de choix bah voilà on
arrête super Phénix pour faire plaisir à
Dominique Voynet on arrête fessenaille
pour respirer que les électeurs vont
voter pour nous avec quel bénéfice pour
les parties 10 républicains et quel
bénéfice pour les écolos aucun je vais
terminer avec
une question sur le le poids de la
France comment vous le vous le ressentez
ce poids dans un événement comme cette
cop27 je donne juste une info puisque
l'objectif de ce débat c'était aussi de
voilà de dire ce qui s'est ce qui
s'annonce à l'occasion de cette COP
acharmer chèque la France a pris une
initiative d'une réunion autour de la
protection des réserves vitales de
carbone et de biodiversité notamment les
forêts anciennes les tourbières et les
mangroves voilà ça fait partie des infos
du jour on va pas avoir le temps de
détailler ce que ça veut dire mais
est-ce que la voix de la France vous
avez le sentiment qu'elle porte
alors la France est quand même
l'architecte de l'accord de Paris et en
soit oui elle a une voix importante dans
les négociations mais nous ce qu'on
déplore beaucoup et c'est un peu ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est cette
posture de toujours se présenter comme
un modèle et de un peu jeter la pierre
aux autres en disant c'est à vous de
faire plus car nous et l'Union
européenne nous sommes déjà nous sommes
déjà acteurs de cette transition et même
si c'est vrai qu'ils sont acteurs de
cette transition et ben nous on attend
beaucoup plus de la France on attend
beaucoup plus de l'Union européenne et
donc du coup ce ton qui est parfois un
peu voilà donneur de leçons et pas
forcément le plus constructif dans les
négociations internationales surtout
quand on sait que la France c'est quand
même le 12e émetteur mondial
historiquement donc elle a un poids et
il faudrait qu'elle l'utilise de manière
plus constructive parfois dans ces dans
ces négociations merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat depuis
charme échec et évidemment ici en
plateau merci à tous Frédéric dans les
rappels le titre de votre livre
rencontre avec des écolos remarquable il
est publié aux éditions de la chaux et
nièce